Film Courage: You did a Reddit AMA I think and you
said that art saved your life? Dar Dixon, Actor: Yes oh my
gosh you should you actually Wow I love
you you've done homework. Yes I did a
Reddit AMA it was something that was
recommended that I do and and I
personally myself as an artist and as an
entrepreneur which I'll talk about that
in a minute because I think it's
important I I think it's important to
constantly push my boundaries in my
comfort zone and my parameters expand my
horizons see what's out there so I did
this AMA on reddit and I did say that
art did save my life because it did
that's a long story that's a longer
answer but I'm happy to talk about it
can you do a Reader's Digest version
Reader's Digest version boy we're gonna
dive right in okay I'm not giving away
my age there so The Reader's Digest
version okay so the Reader's Digest
version i zigged when I should have
zagged and I got caught up in this kind
of New Age doomed a doomsday cult and
took about 20 years out of my life yeah
Wow
exactly exactly okay yeah so by all
means I shouldn't vote by many
parameters definitions etc I shouldn't
be able to be like doing as well as I
can but that's you know I've been
working at things so why do we get on
that question oh the AMA Arts saved my
life so in that process of getting
myself out of that cult and the
brainwashing the mind-control what are
you want to call it that goes with it I
always wanted to be a performer I always
loved the arts singing dancing acting
writing playing music all of it
you know I loved it but I just didn't
get the support that I needed to keep
pursuing that and then you know there
are other things that happen in life
along the way and so I'm like I just
went full bore into acting and you know
you work you work it out in an acting
class you know it's a safe space
hopefully sometimes it's not and you've
got to look out for that
but you know it it encourages and
enables the person the individual to be
able to explore you know some dark
territory some dark emotions some taboo
emotions some dangerous places
emotionally some some weird places
whatever it may be and you know
subsequently that helped me in ways that
I didn't even really understand I didn't
go there and go well it's gonna be
therapy for me or whatever but it
certainly it certainly was the case for
me and yeah man it did it saved my life
it really did yeah so without going too
much into the cold yeah were you did you
have another career that you were doing
before I did I was yeah I guess for I've
kind of always had an entrepreneurial
spirit ever since I was a little boy I'm
like a boy I asked my dad if I could use
the lawn mower when I was I don't know
it was like seven or eight years old and
he looked at me he's like why so nice I
want to go mow some lawns and he just
kind of smiled he was okay and so I just
went down the street and started
knocking on my neighbor's doors hey you
know I'm on your lawn for you didn't
have a price or anything in mind I just
figured I was just like the kindness of
people and I'd go out there and mow the
lawn and rake it up and put it in
plastic bags and like I'm seven or eight
years old I thought that's you know I
saw that's how my father did it and
that's how you're supposed to do it
that's how it was done and invariably
everybody would be staring out their
windows just watching this young kid
like working then they was come here so
diligent I didn't know what that meant
you know you're so thorough this is
great and they would give me five and
ten dollars which you know back in those
days was a lot of money and it became
quickly apparent to me that you know
this was something I like to do I
enjoyed the whole every aspect of it the
the hustle the the drive to go out knock
you have to create something and then
follow through and and provide the
service and do a good job and make the
customer happy and hopefully they'll
tell somebody else you come back
again this was way more fun than going
and saying you know hey can I scoop ice
cream err and there's not that there's
anything wrong with that but for me the
way I was wired that that's always been
what I did so yeah I had I've owned and
operated several businesses most of them
not successfully but that's where you
learn you know you fall down flat on
your face and lose money just screw the
pooch in any number of ways and you know
you you know that didn't work I won't do
that again and you start to learn all
that work I'll do more of that I'll just
keep doing that and yeah that's that's
been what I've done so at that time I'd
had a we started at ironically in that
cult we started a painting business and
and we were kind of struggling and then
threw out the idea that you know maybe
we should go after the affluent market
where people who have a lot of money and
they don't necessarily worry about price
so much as they do the quality of the
work and and you not being a pain in
their backside and so we started to go
after the big-name designers this was in
New York City at the time in the 80s and
yeah
we got a couple of designers gave us a
break and we got a chance to do like one
bedroom for I'm not gonna start naming
names but for some very affluent clients
and they liked it and word started to
spread and within a year we had more
work than we could handle and we had we
were booked out you know months in
advance and you know when you our whole
thing was doing a great job like doing a
job that they didn't expect going above
and beyond and like I said you know I
learned this when I was like eight years
old so you know I showed up at this one
very wealthy woman woman's apartment she
owned like the entire and I was like the
tenth floor of a very well-known
building in the Upper West Side and I
walked in and this was the gig man this
is that I knew I knew what to do I just
I knew from all these trial and error
that she wanted her place to look
pristine and you walk in it was gorgeous
it was absolutely beautiful not my style
but tasteful elegant beautiful and we're
gonna repaint the place so I walked in
with a disposable camera took pictures
to all around the room and I the entire
apartment and I asked the maid or the
housekeeper excuse me ask the
housekeeper if I could be excused I need
to go develop the film and she looked at
me like I what and she said well let me
go ask mrs. and I said okay and so I did
and they gave me the blessing and I went
down to the our film developing I came
back and I put everything and all the
pictures inside of a photo album and
they're watching me out of the corner of
my eye and I was like I got him and it
was method to my madness but it was also
you know I wanted to let them know just
they could just start to relax and that
tension on their shoulders could start
to dissipate and then I got the other
guys that were with me and we started to
just mask off the floor with first we
put down sisal paper they call it the
brown kind of absorbent paper and we
taped off every square inch of the floor
right and then we put plastic over that
we put another layer of drop cloth over
that like the floor wasn't gonna get
damaged and they're just looking at me
out of the corner like very good very
good so anyway I don't know why we're
talking about that but yeah that's that
was the level of work that we did and we
did well we did well with it but at some
point you decided that sorry there was a
lot of insanity going on as I said
because that was the business and that
was the face of you know that was our
business but then like the insanity of
that group was always an undercurrent
all the time and like that's a whole
other story I mean we would talk about
that for hours but yes but at some point
you said you know what I want to try
this acting thing I will I always did
and I kind of dabbled in it from it from
a distance
and but I was really you know honest I
was just petrified to do it I was afraid
to put myself you know on camera you
know your first time you see yourself on
camera I think this goes for pretty much
everyone you just oh my god oh my god
you just start beating yourself up which
doesn't do anybody any good all right
but it's shocking the first time you
hear your voice and you see yourself on
camera and how you do things and how you
say things and etc so I I really went
all-in and I got really lucky right away
and got my Screen Actors Guild card with
pretty much my first audition Wow
I know I know that rarely if ever
happens was on a show that used to be
shot down in San Diego with Stu Segal
productions Stu is a great guy had
studio set up down there and he did a
show called silk stockings yes 18 wheels
of justice was the other one
wings of gold something I can't remember
I can't wear the other one but yeah he
shot those shows down there and I got my
first my first gig working with Rob
Estes and Mindy I forgot Mindy's last
name sorry Mindy really great actors
great people on silk stockings yeah
so then how was it for you know cuz
you're you're living off that high and
maybe the paycheck of the job but then
the weird part is then who then it comes
down and now you're drumming up work and
now that clock is ticking for the first
of the month you know what's interesting
about that you're right
you're right that occurred and I had a
bunch of crazy notions in my head about
you know what acting was and what you
know the what what what would happen you
know like all these crazy ideas of
celebrity and money and stardom and
stuff that wasn't what I was aiming for
but the funny thing was you just hit the
nail on the head you know if you're
gonna succeed in this business whatever
if you're going to be writing directing
producing acting singing dancing
whatever it is whatever aspect it's
contingent upon your ability
you keep picking up the phone keep
sending the emails following up going to
networking events or going to meetings
or whatever you get out there and start
to circulate in nurturing relationships
and I did that in business but for
whatever reason when I got into acne was
just like hi I'm here and I'm not sure
why I did that the only thing I can
think the reason that I may have done
that was because it was so therapeutic
in so many ways there was less judgment
in the beginning stages at least through
these eyes there were you know when
you're in an acting class like it was a
very forgiving space largely and that
was like holy this is you know my heart
just like started to open up this is
fantastic and you could get weird like I
said you can give funny you could get
serious you get loud you'd get ugly
whatever right
tender powerful whatever it may be and
and I think I well I needed that clearly
I needed that and I turned off the
business part of my brain and I wish I
hadn't but you know everyone's path is
different that's not the case these days
but it certainly was in the beginning
you said something interesting you said
that in the beginning it was a safe
space and that people were encouraging
or you just felt like accepted do you
think as you rise in the ranks that
changes yeah it can of course I mean
that's very kind of naive on my part and
it's also accurate you know you can't
create a performance in a place where
you don't feel safe and yet this isn't
anything that no one's I heard a million
times you want to be you got to feel
comfortable and safe with your director
with the crew members with producers
with you know a screenwriter with the
whoever it is you've got to feel that
you know we're all in this together
we're trying to create something
and but you know as necessarily as you
as you start working on bigger and
bigger projects you know you're stepping
into a business and if they're
successful ones if they've been around a
long time there are well oiled machine
and you're just there to move a
storyline along or you're there to play
you know whatever X Factor is in that
story in that script in the parameters
of that show and those characters in
that world and you know if you forget
that not not a resource we'll know so
but but but I I think that yeah it still
can be a safe space but of course then
you know it's it's it's commerce you're
in business so you have to you have to
factor that in I believe that that
doesn't happen often enough with a lot
of actors well you know to be fair
actors take a beating all the time
because they think like you know look
all talking and moving background some
guy said one time I was like really wow
that's amazing when you feel comfortable
enough to say that to me what was your
name again I didn't catch it right but
you have to often actors I I have seen
too often that they will not embrace
business aspect but as I said to be fair
I see writers doing the same thing I see
directors doing the same thing I see
some producers doing the same thing
which seems counterintuitive but they it
happens I've seen it happen they don't
take the business aspect into play
enough it is called show business and
really it should probably go up the
business of show because if you want to
create or perform whatever your art is
whatever your your instrument your
vehicle is for for expressing your your
artistry you can do it on any street
corner right but if we're here in
Hollywood then necessarily you are
looking to make a mark make a statement
and be paid for it and that's great but
you you
going to do that then you need to
understand how businesses work
you